let's bring in Molly Hemingway now she's
a Fox News contributor and
editor-in-chief at the Federalist Molly
it seems like we're reaching some kind
of a critical mass here now where the
Border crisis
has infected the East Coast it seems
undeniable now in Democratic strongholds
even like New York City that
it is happening yeah well when you look
at the 6 million illegal border
crossings or illegal immigrants that we
have in the country since the Biden
Administration took over we think a lot
about how the cartels have engaged in
human trafficking all the human rights
violations that go with that we think
about the fentanyl that has crossed the
border leading to a hundred thousand
deaths recently of Americans but we also
you know now you're seeing New York City
deal with what a lot of cities and small
towns throughout the country have been
dealing with because of our lack of
control over the Border when you have
this flood of immigrants of illegal
immigrants and also the drugs and other
problems that come with it it can cause
a lot of administration problems New
York City is what we're seeing I suppose
New York City's mayor yeah was was
speaking a really big game when the
Trump Administration was trying to
control the Border talking about how New
York City would always welcome everyone
whether they're Asylum Seekers or
otherwise illegal immigrants and now
he's actually having to deal with the
problem and it's clearly not going very
well do you think it is
there is still a chance that he can sort
of get a hold of the situation
start managing this in a way that is
sustainable for the city or this is all
the feud with the mayor with the
governor this is all sort of like
rearranging deck chairs on the Titanic I
think this will continue to be a very
big problem which is why so many people
are con concerned about it I mean it's
really a bipartisan problem too going
back decades the failure to control the
Border it's something you know you talk
about this border wall that's there left
unconstructed and you remember how
during the Trump Administration he was
asking for what five billion dollars and
even Republican senators were fighting
him on that and you think about that
relative to the 100 billion plus that
has gone to Ukraine you know the Biden
Administration says our plan is working
on controlling the border and in a sense
they're right their plan was always to
open up the Border their plan was always
to to not have construction of a border
wall to to bring in just millions of
illegal border crossers and not do
anything about it so their plan is
working the problem for Americans is
that the plan is not what a lot of
Americans want uh take a listen to
Senator Kirsten Cinema I'm skipping
ahead in our call for list here
um she laid blame
full screen excuse me she laid blame
specifically at the feet of democratic
leaders who she says sent 100 million
dollars in federal border funds to New
York versus just 24 million to her State
then in an interview this week she
singled out uh Senate minority Majority
Leader excuse me Chuck Schumer and
Hakeem Jeffries claiming the reason for
the discrepancy is quote fairly obvious
I don't know if you noticed but the
announcement about that 104 million came
out first in a joint press release from
Schumer and Jeffries not from the White
House or FEMA she called the decision
deeply deeply wrong right so Kirsten
Cinema is running for re-election in
Arizona and she's trying to appeal to
people other than the diamond party that
she was once in but the fact is that she
voted for everything that these people
did including the she voted to confirm
my orcas everyone knew this was the plan
Biden was actually pretty clear about
what his plan was for the Border when he
ran for office it's why you saw a flood
of a flood of border crossings even
before he was inaugurated and people do
pay attention to what the Border policy
of a president is you saw that during
the Trump Administration you also see
that during the Biden Administration so
for her to sort of feign confusion about
what's going on you know financing some
of this what's happening in New York and
not dealing with the Border problems in
Arizona I think is a bit too cute by
half given that everyone was pretty
honest that they wanted to have an open
border and they have worked
steadfastly to ensure that beginning on
day one you know Biden talked about how
his first objective when he took office
his day one was to take away some of
those executive orders from the previous
administration to ensure that he would
be able to uphold what he claimed he
wanted to do of having this uh making of
taking away the Trump Administration
border policies that he ran against all
right well we got to leave it there
thanks for joining us as always thanks
thanks Molly hey everyone I'm Emily
compagno catch me and my co-host Harris
Faulkner and Kaylee mcineny on
outnumbered every weekday at 12 pm
Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights